Every now and again, a pairing comes along that makes absolute perfect sense.
De Niro and Pacino, Damon and Afleck, Deadpool and Spiderman..
..Despite being tasked with saving the world over and over again, superheroes are still human,
Well, most of them are at least.
But human or not, these characters all have friends..
and have bonded to bromance level status with some of their costumed peers.
Here are ScreenRant's 10 Marvel Superhero Bromances That Actually Happened.
If you have fun watching our video, why don't you web-swing on over to that like button..
..and don't forget to subscribe for more awesome videos like this one.
And before we start, can you guess this movie from these emojis?
Stay tuned for the answer at the end of our video.
(Capt.) I thought you were dead
(Bucky) I thought you were smaller.
Captain America and the Winter Soldier.
You know you're destined to be bros for life, when you wake up seventy-odd years later..
And make it your life's mission to save your once- presumed dead friend, and protect him..
From the clutches of the law.. and evil-Nazi cults.
Steve Rogers and Bucky Barnes were childhood friends, who grew up together
in Brooklyn before the second world war..
Despite being scrawny and weak, he found kinship with the dashing Bucky Barnes, and the two were
Inseprable
Even during the war when Captain America disobeyed orders and saved a group of soldiers..
..Including the injured Barnes.
Even though Barnes was presumed dead, he would reunite with Cap in the 21st century
and unfortunately they would come to blows.
Despite Bucky being a mind-controlled assassin..
Cap did his best to bring his friend back.
And eventually succeeded in doing so.
He later did his best to protect Barnes from both the international authorities and from Iron Man.
Who was out on a vendetta on the former assassin.
We think Cap and Bucky may set the bar for what bros would do for each other.
(Prof. X)"You're going to have to do for me, what I once did for you, lead me, guide me.."
Wolverine and Professor X
After the world apparently fell apart..
long-time buddies, Logan and Charles Xavier, hit the road and went into hiding south of the border
These two hit it off from the moment they met each other.
With Logan finding a mentor and a friend in the telepathic professor.
There may be an age difference between the two of them, with Logan being Charles' senior and all..
But when you're bros, age is only a number
Charles helped Logan piece together his terrible past.
While also acting as a much-needed friend
When old age came knocking for the two of them, Logan did his best to take care of the Professor.
Despite being unsure as to how exactly to take care of anyone.
We figure he gave it his best given his unstable condition.
But when crisis came-a-calling the first and only priority was the protection of his oldest friend.
When that becomes instinct number one, you know you're bros.
Luke Cage and Iron Fist
It's only a matter of time before one of comic books favorite bromances makes its way to the small screen.
Making up half of the Defenders, Luke Cage and Iron Fist first hit it off in the 1970's in the comics..
during a time when Kung Fu and Blaxploitation were quite popular.
Despite having the foundations, the two characters were not a big hit initially..
So what happens when you bring two unpopular forces together into the same room?
They obviously create the biggest bromance the seventies has ever seen on paper.
And generate sales.
Unlike most superhero teams such as Avengers or the  X-men, the Defenders don't have much in the way of superpowers.
Relying often on their superior fighting skills that have been enhanced in some way, shape or form.
This ends up feeling like an old-buddy cop film in the comibook form.
(Iron Man rapidly)"Got to sleep go to sleep go to sleep"
Iron Man and Hulk
When he's not stealing the limelight as a genius, billionaire, playboy, philanthropist, Tony Stark
can be found talking scientific theory with his buddy, Bruce Banner.
The only person who's on the same intellectual level as him.
Over their love of science, the two have formed a super bromance that may have been too trusting.
As the ever-cautious Bruce Banner helped Tony Stark create the giant murderbot known as Ultron.
Well hey, only best friends forever accidentally create Earth-ending situations
And only best friends stick around to clean up the mess.
I mean Thor went straight for the one-armed choke against Tony
We don't think there's any bromance going on there.
But Thor may end up stealing the thunder from Dr.Banner as they team up for the events of Thor Ragnarok(Doomsday)
(??)"You have the most powerful brain in the world Professor, but the mind can only stretch so far before
it snaps."
Professor X and Magneto
They may be sworn enemies, but there's no denying Charles Xavier's intellectual and spiritual other half is Erik Lehnsher.
Otherwise known as Magneto
The two met in the 1960's and have stuck with each other over the decades
Despite constantly fighting and arguing
Even when Magneto gets imprisoned for trying to turn normal humans into mutants, Charles Xavier is there for his friend.
Stopping by regularly to play a round of chess with the imprisoned supervillain.
They may often come to blows, may even hate each other at the best of times,
But only true bros can eventually put that behind them in the end and team up to save the world
Daredevil and the Punsiher
friend well that friend becomes your bro
which is the case for Frank Castle and
Matt Murdock they may not always get
along but the to have an understanding
of the world that most other people just
don't see and get it see they may
disagree on ethics and morality but in
the end both vigilantes want the same
thing which gives the Punisher someone
to confide his thoughts to he may not
realize it but daredevil is extremely
important for the well being of the
Punisher with their rapport the to try
to keep each other out of harm's way
both from criminal and from the clutches
of the police department The Punisher
even once traded his life for Daredevils
in the comics way to take one for the
team Punisher you're welcome the
Warriors three unlike the rest of the
pairings on our list this bromance comes
from a trio of battle hardy Asgardian
warriors comprised of Fandral hogan and
Volstagg the dynamic trio are always
ready for battle and a drink not
necessarily in that order the Warriors
Three often head into battle with the
almighty Thor and the ladies sit making
one of the greatest fighting forces in
the cosmos the trio and Roy recounting
their tails in bars and taverns across
as God often exaggerating their tails to
make them seem even more spectacular
than they already are no matter what the
task at hand is these three will do
anything for each other even if that
means springing a supervillain out of
jail or disobeying the direct orders of
Odin himself to bring Thor back to
Asgard through thick and thin these
brave warriors will always have each
other's backs Christopher entry surgeon
arion Hawkeye and black widow not every
bromance has to be between teeth dudes
in fact one of the biggest bromances out
there in the Marvel Universe comes from
the friendship between Hawkeye and black
widow they may be strapped for super
but together these two make one hell of
a team the two have a long history which
was established after Natasha Romanov
left the dark and dangerous employment
of the Russian government she eventually
met up with Quinn Barton and joined
shield will be changing the purpose of
her life and erasing the red in her
ledger she owes a lot too quick and he's
one of the few people to former assassin
actually trust you know you're on
bromance levels of friendship when
you're in the know about the secret
family that nobody else knows about
Rocket Raccoon and Groot I am Groot that
was group speak for you're my best
friend which is exactly what the dynamic
duo Rocket Raccoon and groups are the
two buddies travel across the galaxy as
bounty hunters catching unsavory
individuals and trading them in for some
hard-earned cash despite Groot only
being able to speak three words rocket
actually understands the meaning behind
every different iteration of paigham
groups which must mean the world to him
imagine if no one else to really
understand him and Groot was left all
alone unable to communicate yeah we got
sad just thinking of it too that's why
Rocket Raccoon and roots are meant to be
and have the most intergalactic bromance
out there they stick together no matter
what so you gotta hold on to love tight
Deadpool and spider-man we don't think
it can get any more bromance than these
two I mean just look at them in case you
didn't know Deadpool was initially based
on spider-man's concept model so these
two are about as close to being Inc
brothers as you can get when not dishing
out the pain on the scum and villainy of
the world these two are cracking one
whiners like it's nobody's business a
more recent comic publication soft
spider-man questioning the dark and
gritty nature of modern superhero films
to which Deadpool replied that he would
not do his own movie unless it was all
rated Wade Wilson is known for being
immature and silly but Peter Parker
seems to bring out the trials in the
Canadian super mutant which makes their
bromance all the more special they're
funny and they're clearly besties
despite having completely different
views on well just about everything
those are our picks for 10 marvel
superhero bromances that actually happen
do you agree with our list what's your
favorite superhero bromance whatever it
is let us know in the comments section
below the fun never stops here though as
there is even more awesome content over
X VB are so head on over that way for
even more geeky videos thanks for
watching
you